I mean I think Christian Bale did like
just such a I mean it's so kind of
iconic like as the the voice that he was
doing in it but it's almost impossible
to to not to not do that where were the
other drugs going I don't know I swear
to God it's really hard to get into a
artificially blower register I mean and
it was and to do it a long time because
I mean there's a lot of scenes in this
as well where you're kind of it's long
dialogue scenes as Batman which is quite
unique out of um a lot of the other
movies in the series and trying to kind
of stay really really low
and have kind of nuance in the lines and
stuff I mean it's really hard it's
really really hard